ich eröffne die Aussprache und zuerst
hat das Wort für die FDP-Fraktion
Stephan Thomé
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren heute bringen wir als Fortis
Koalition zu einem guten Ende war es die
unionsgeführte Vorgängerregierung nicht
mehr in der letzten Wahlperiode
geschafft hat denn eigentlich hätte die
europäische
Hinweisgeber Richtlinie bereits bis zum
17.12.2021 also morgen vor einem Jahr
umgesetzt werden müssen und heute
beschließen wir als Deutsche Bundestag
das Gesetz für einen besseren Schutz
Hinweis geben der Personen und schaffen
dadurch endlich mehr Rechtssicherheit
meine Damen und Herren
denn hinweisgeberinnen und Hinweisgeber
leisten einen wichtigen Beitrag zur
Aufdeckung und Handlung von Missständen
und gesetzlichen Verstößen sind aber
bislang oft nur sehr unzureichend
geschützt die allermeisten Unternehmen
handeln natürlich ohnehin nach Recht und
Gesetz schaffen Arbeitsplätze sorgen für
Wohlstand im Land und sie haben zu dem
selbst Interesse daran dass Missstände
im eigenen Unternehmen erkannt und
angezeigt werden um sie selbst
schnellstmöglich zu beheben ein
effektives Meldeverfahren und einen
entsprechendes Compliance Management
sind daher keine Schikane sondern eine
echte Chance für Unternehmen noch besser
zu werden meine Damen und Herren viele
Unternehmen haben das auch schon längst
selbst erkannt und entsprechend
Vorkehrungen getroffen haben bereits
Compliance Abteilungen und Hinweisgeber
Systeme angewandt mit dem heutigen
Gesetz sorgen wir für den notwendigen
Schutz Hinweis geben der Personen ohne
dabei Unternehmen unnötig zu belasten
Rechtssicherheit und Praxis Tauglichkeit
das waren die größten Herausforderungen
bei der Umsetzung der europäischen
Richtlinie der Bundesjustizminister und
sein Haus haben auch der Richtlinie
schon ein sehr sehr gutes Gesetz gemacht
vielen Dank für die Vorarbeiten hierfür
und in der Koalition haben wir den
Entwurf noch einmal intensiv und sehr
konzentriert beraten und noch einigen
Stellen ein paar weitere Verbesserungen
vornehmen können dafür auch nein danke
meine britischer Kollegen vieler und
Kollegen Dr Steffen
auch ein paar Punkte die mir wichtig
sind möchte ich jetzt noch kurz eingehen
erstens wir ermöglichen konzernmeldewege
das ist extrem wichtig und in der Sache
auch völlig richtig denn natürlich macht
es Sinn dass in einem Konzern aber auch
bei
ollision wie dem Deutschen Roten Kreuz
nicht jede kleinste Einheiten gerade mal
50 Mitarbeitern eine eigene Meldestelle
einrichten muss es ist doch die Konzern
zentrale die Leitung des ganzen wissen
muss was bei ihren Tochterunternehmen
vor sich geht um hier Abhilfe zu
schaffen
zweitens wir schaffen Anreize dafür dass
sie der Hinweisgeber zunächst an den
internen Meldeweg halten soll denn
eigentlich ist ziel ist es doch nicht
dass jemand extern und öffentlich
angefangen hat wird sondern das intern
bekannt wird wir haben bei uns im
Unternehmen Missstände und die wollen
wir selbst abstellen 3 wir sehen nun vor
dass auch anonyme Meldungen bearbeitet
werden müssen und zwar nicht nachrangig
zur nicht anonymen Meldungen denn es
macht doch keinen Sinn wenn Unternehmen
zum Beispiel auf anonymen Wege von
gravierenden Missständen kennt das aber
zurückstellen muss weil andere nicht an
dem Gemälde Bagatellen zunächst einmal
bearbeitet werden müssen
und viertens gerade nach den
Erkenntnissen über rechtsextreme
chatgruppen in Behörden ohne
Zusammenhang mit den Razzien in
reichsbürgerszene ist es doch absolut
richtig das Hinweisgeber auch geschützt
werden müssen wenn sie Verstöße gegen
die Pflicht zur Verfassungstreue in
Behörden melden Extremisten Reichsbürger
Faschisten Neonazis einfach nichts
verloren meine Damen und Herren
und lassen Sie mich abschließend noch
Stellung nehmen zum einigen
Befürchtungen die in der Öffentlichkeit
geführt worden sind erstens das
hinweisgeberschutz fördert kein
Denunziantentum es führt auch keinen
Generalverdacht gegen Unternehmen viel
mehr schafft das Gesetz die rechtlichen
Voraussetzungen dafür dass zunächst
unter dem selbst von Fehlentwicklungen
und Missständen Kenntnis erhalten und
selber die Möglichkeit haben diese
Missstände abzustellen der
hinweisgeberschutz greift auch dann
nicht wenn jemand bewusst
Falschmeldungen nach außen geben und die
Unternehmen selber sagen uns doch wir
gehen ja ohnehin allen Hinweisen nach
völlig egal ob sie im Anwendungsbereich
des Gesetzes liegen oder oder außerhalb
denn für uns Unternehmen ist einzige
entscheidend um sich um substanzierte
Hinweise handelt deshalb und das ist
auch noch ein abschließendes Wort an die
Union was ich mir gewünscht hätte das
wäre wenn die Union dieses Vorhaben
konstruktiver positive begleitet hätte
denn wir bringen hier zu Ende was sie in
jeder Zeit nicht geschafft haben schade
dass wir auf ihr Hilfe nicht vertrauen
konnten aber mein Dank an den
Justizminister an das Ministerium und an
die Kolleginnen und Kollegen der anderen
Fraktion der Koalition für die wertvolle
Mitarbeit bedanke mich und freue mich
dass wir dieses Gesetz verabschieden
können
nächster Redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
DR Martin Plum
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die heutige
Debatte bietet einen guten Anlass mit
einigen Aussagen aus dem Reich der
Märchen sagen und Fabelwelt aufzuräumen
ausgesprochen oder geschrieben haben sie
nicht etwa die Gebrüder Grimm sondern
die Brüder und Schwestern
ampelkoalitionäre erste Aussage wir
setzen die eu-wistelbohrer Richtlinie
rechtssicher und praktikabel um dieses
struktursa findet sich in ihrem
Koalitionsvertrag der vorliegende
Gesetzentwurf ist weder das eine noch
das andere er wimmelt vor unbestimmten
Rechtsbegriffen erklärt sein Verhältnis
zu bestehenden meldesystemen etwa nach
dem Lieferketten sorgfaltspflichtgesetz
nicht er schafft keinerlei Anreize für
die sinnvolle Nutzung interner Meldewege
Aufgaben und Befugnisse der Meldestelle
bleiben schwammig das Verhältnis der
externen Meldestellen zu anderen
Behörden bleibt bestimmt das ist rechts
unsicher das ist praktikabel und das ist
dann Summe ein großes
Beschäftigungsprogramm für unsere
ohnehin überlasteten Gerichte
zweite Aussage
hinweisgeberschutz ist
Unternehmensschutz drei Mal haben sie
lieber Herr Bundesminister Buschmann
diese drei Worte in der ersten Beratung
des Gesetzentwurfs am 29 September
gesagt dreimal zu viel denn das
Gegenteil ist der Fall 90.000
Unternehmen in unserem Land belasten sie
durch dieses Gesetz mit zusätzlichen
Kosten und neuer Bürokratie und schenken
ihnen noch nicht mal einen Wein ein sie
haben hier am 29 September behauptet ich
zitiere 70% der Großunternehmen und etwa
40% der KMU hätten heute schon
Meldestellen eine Studie vom 22
September eine Woche zuvor kommt zu
einem ganz anderen Ergebnis
19% der Unternehmen haben danach gerade
mal Hinweisgebersysteme vollständig
implementiert die kleinen und
mittelständischen Unternehmen in ihren
Wahlkreisen werden sich sicher über
dieses Weihnachtsgeschenk in ihrem
Hausaufgabenheft freuen lieber
ampelkoalitionäre
dritte Aussage wir nutzen alle
flexibilitätsspielräume der Richtlinie
aus auch das haben sie lieber Herr
Bundesminister Buschmann hier am 29
September gesagt und das führt ihre
Koalition mit ihren Änderungsanträgen
jetzt endgültig absurden während die
Richtlinie die Entscheidung ob anonyme
Meldungen möglich sind den
Mitgliedstaaten überlässt satteln sie an
diesem Punkt munter drauf sie
entscheiden sich nicht nur für anonyme
Meldungen sondern verpflichten 90.000
Unternehmen in unserem Land künftig dazu
anonyme meldekanäle einzurichten und sie
tun das im vollen Bewusstsein dass damit
zusätzliche Kosten und Belastungen für
die Unternehmen verbunden sind in der
Begründung ihrer Änderungsanträge heißt
es anonyme meldekanäle ich zitiere sind
mit Zusatzkosten für die notwendigen
technischen Vorrichtungen oder die
Einschaltung einer Ombudsperson
verbunden so wie mit einer zusätzlichen
Belastung durch den erhöhten Aufwand für
die Einrichtung der Meldestellen
erklären sie auch das gerne mal
persönlich in ihren Wahlkreisen und vor
allem hätte sagen Sie dann bitte auch
dass das keine unnötige Bürokratie für
unsere Unternehmen ist
vierte Aussage uns ist es gelungen die
Rechtsansicht der Kommission zum Wohle
der Unternehmen zu ändern auch das haben
sie lieber Herr Bundesminister Buschmann
hier am 29 September gesagt fragt man
ihr Ministerium welche konkreten
Änderungen das denn sein sollen herrscht
Schweigen in Wald in der Antwort auf
meine Frage heißt sie sich zitiere
wieder das Bundesministerium der Justiz
nimmt regelmäßig an den Treffen einer
Expertengruppe teil und bringt doch
seine Rechtsansichten ein Aha von
Änderungen zum Boden der Unternehmen
keine Spur fragt man dann gezielt nach
der von Ihnen ausdrücklich in Bezug
genommen konzernlösung wieder Schweigen
im Wald ich zitiere der Austausch mit
der Kommission zu dieser Frage ist noch
nicht abgeschlossen von Änderungen zum
Wohle der Unternehmen keine Spur
fakt ist damit die sinnvolle
konzernlösung ist bis heute nicht Europa
rechtlich abgesichert und sie lassen
alle Konzerne Unternehmen damit im Regen
der Rechtsunsicherheit steht
fünfte Aussage es wird sorgfältig darauf
geachtet dass während der Krise keine
unverhältnismäßigen zusätzlichen
Bürokratie Lasten die Wirtschaft
beeinträchtigen
das haben sie lieber Herr Bundesminister
Buschmann ausnahmsweise einmal nicht in
der ersten Beratung gesagt es stammt
aber vom selben Tag es ist ihr groß
postuliertes belastungsmoratorium dass
sie das mit diesem Gesetz vollkommen
absurdum führen dürfte inzwischen jeden
hier im Saat klar geworden sein aber
gerne noch ein paar Zahlen 90.000
Unternehmen in unserem Land lassen Sie
nach der ursprünglichen Begründung ihres
Gesetzentwurfs mit einmaligen Kosten von
rund 200 Millionen Euro in Folgekosten
von weiteren 200 Millionen Euro Jahr für
Jahr legt man realistischere
Berechnungen zugrunde sind es sogar 400
Millionen Euro Jahr für Jahr und die
Zusatzkosten durch ihre Änderungsanträge
kommen noch an top fast eine halbe
Milliarde Euro stellen Sie unseren
Unternehmen damit jedes Jahr in Rechnung
stellen Sie diese Rechnungen bitte vor
Weihnachten persönlich an die
betroffenen Unternehmen in ihren
Wahlkreisen zu
Fazit ihre Koalition verbindet nur ein
Motto mehr Bürokratie Wagen das ist die
Formel auf die sie sich immer wieder
gerne und genüsslich einigen und das
zeigt eines deutlich sie sind keine
Regierungskoalition sie sind eine
regulierungskoalition
nächster Redner für die SPD-Fraktion
Sebastian Fiedler
[Applaus]
liebe Frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen Liebe interessierte das ist
eigentlich eine ganz gute Gelegenheit
ein paar Dinge noch mal zurechtzurücken
und sozusagen das Gesamtbild noch einmal
zu schärfen denn es ist ja so wir stehen
ja heute erst hier deswegen weil in der
letzten Legislatur mit der Union leider
nichts hingekriegt worden ist wir hätten
eigentlich ein Gesetz schon vor
anderthalb Jahren haben können wenn das
mit ihnen gegangen wäre dazu habe ich
aber von ihnen irgendwie gar nichts
gehört Bürokratie war das Hauptthema
ich finde wir haben ganz gutes Gesetz
hingekriegt es gibt mir aber die
Gelegenheit das noch einmal auch für
alle Interessierten die sich nicht mit
allen Details beschäftigt haben ist in
den gesamten gesellschaftlichen Rahmen
einzuordnen ich glaube dass es nämlich
wichtig denn man muss erklären wir haben
uns in der Gesellschaft gewissen Normen
und Werten verschrieben
Gesetze kommen demokratisch Zustande
normengerechtes Verhalten der
Menschenrecht dazu bei dass wir im
gesellschaftlichen Frieden leben können
und das ist eigentlich so etwas was
insgesamt glaube ich ja zu selten
diskutiert wird wir sprechen viel über
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt und das
eine hat hier glaube ich schon sehr sehr
viel miteinander zu tun denn wir haben
wir haben ganz viele regulative in der
Gesellschaft wir haben das im ganz
kleinen in der Familie dann nennt man
das Erziehung wenn Verstöße gegen Normen
passieren wir haben das in
Organisationsformen wir kennen
schiedsgerichtete bei Parteien oder bei
Vereinen und wir kennen das auch hier im
Raum die Frau Präsidentin kann
Ordnungsmaßnahmen erlassen und ich bin
heute ehrlich gesagt ganz froh dass
nicht vor 50 Jahren Rede weil wie ich
gehört habe vor 50 Jahren hätte ich
heute einen Ordnungsruf gekriegt weil
ich keine Krawatte trage also es ist
offenbar so Normen und Werte ändern sich
auch warum ich das alles erzähle
tatsächlich das ist deswegen wichtig
weil ich glaube wir müssen das noch mal
herausärfen es gibt eben bestimmte
Normen und Werte der ist ja Unrecht
Gehalt so hoch dass wir sagen wir haben
da Ordnungswidrigkeiten Straftaten
Bestände definiert wir haben das
Gewaltmonopol des Staates also die
staatlichen Organisationen damit betraut
diese entsprechend zu ahnen aber der
Punkt über den wir heute sprechen ist
die Frage der Aufdeckung also wie kommt
es eigentlich überhaupt zur Aufdeckung
solcher Normen und Werte und es ist eben
wichtig dass diese Aufdeckung aus der
Gesellschaft herauskommt weil wir eben
gerade nicht dass dem Gewaltmonopol
überlassen wollen dann wären wir in
einem Überwachungsstaat sowie in China
und das wollen wir gerade eben alle
nicht
und wenn wir jetzt über Hinweisgeber
sprechen wisselbauer der englische
Begriff dann ist das etwas aus der
Normalität der Gesellschaft aus der
Normalität des Alltags eine Zahl etwa 90
Prozent der Strafverfahren die bei der
Polizei bearbeitet werden kommen nur
deswegen zustande weil es anzeigen und
Hinweise gibt nicht etwa weil die
Ermittlungsbehörden etwas aufgedeckt
haben und die größten Skandal über die
wir zu diskutieren hatten paar
Stichworte Panama papers Paradise papers
Lux leaks Swiss secrets also die größten
Steuerdaten unserer Genosse Norbert
Walter Baujahr das könnte ein Lied davon
sehen was das entsprechend bedeutet die
kommen da gibt es mehr Erfolge zu
verzeichnen als die größten
internationalen
strafverfolgungsermittlung überhaupt zu
Tage befördert hatten und deswegen ist
es sehr wichtig und wir sollten die
Gelegenheit nutzen und lieber dr Plum
dazu haben sie keine Silbe verloren das
ist eben diesen mutigen Menschen und der
Courage dieser Menschen zu verdanken ist
sie genießen unseren Respekt und unsere
Anerkennung unseren allerhöchsten Dank
und ihnen gebührt ein großer Applaus an
der Stelle sie haben nur über Bürokratie
geredet keine Silbe darüber wecken
wertvollen Beitrag hinweisgeberinnen und
Hinweisgeber hinterlassen und wir müssen
deswegen ein Gesetz machen weil es eben
Schwächen gibt weil es immer mal wieder
passiert dass hinweisgebenden
personenrepressalien drohen sie werden
zu Unrecht entlassen aus dem Unternehmen
und deswegen geht es im Prinzip in
diesem Gesetz um zweierlei Dinge auf der
einen Seite schützen wir Hinweis gebende
Personen vor Repressalien und auf der
anderen Seite verpflichten wir
Organisationen dazu entsprechende
Stellen einzurichten die professionell
mit diesen Hinweisen umgehen können das
ist ein wichtiger Punkt und im Übrigen
muss dem Bundesjustizminister
selbstverständlich Recht geben die
Aufdeckung
unternehmensintern solcher Themen und
solcher Korruptionsverfahren oder
ähnlicher Straftaten die natürlich der
Wirtschaft und beschützt die Wirtschaft
und es verhindert größere Skandale das
ist doch außerordentlich klar eigentlich
finde ich
und Liebe Union das hätten wir alles
schon haben können Christine Lambrecht
hatte ein sehr guten Vorschlag gemacht
und hatte schon Kompromisse vorgelegt
aber sie wollten nur eine Eins zu Eins
Umsetzung der EU-Regeln das hätte dazu
geführt dass selbst Meldungen zu
Straftaten zu Dingen die wir hier als
besonders verwerflich erachten nicht zum
Schutz von Hinweis gebenden Personen
geführt hatten sie machen da offenbar
nach meiner Einschätzung ein paar
Denkfehler deswegen ist es gut dass auch
das drucksche Gesetz dazu beigetragen
hat dass gerade auch anonyme Meldungen
jetzt hier verpflichtend bearbeiten
werden müssen wenn sie sich mit
Unternehmensvertretern unterhalten
hätten hätten Sie gewusst dass sie
sowieso dort bearbeitet werden in den
Meldungen es gibt zahlreiche andere
rechtliche Hintergründe warum das mit
allen Unternehmen also mit wirklich für
Mittelständler ich weiß nicht wo sie
unterwegs gewesen weil sie haben
vielleicht nur in die Argumente der
alten Legislatur geguckt aber sich nicht
mit Praktikern unterhalten das haben wir
getan wir haben sehr viel Arbeit
investiert
und wir schützen und das hat der Kollege
Thomas zurecht gesagt gerade in diesen
Tagen natürlich auch und das hätten sie
schon dreimal nicht gewollt auch
hinweisgebende personen die Hinweise auf
verfassungs- und Treue Beamte geben also
muss das tatsächlich ernsthaft noch
erklären in diesen Tagen warum das von
Bedeutung ist dass wir Staatsdiener im
Uniform die einen Herr Brandner dass sie
sich trauen angesichts dieser Themen
hier überhaupt den Mund aufzumachen das
gehört schon da gehört schon wirklich
Mut und Courage zu sie sind doch hier
der Brandstifter Nomen ist oben kann ich
nur sagen ohne ihren ohne ihren Rechte
Grundlage hätten wir diese ganzen
Verschwörung zu Extremisten
wahrscheinlich gar nicht so sie sind
Hass und Hetze genau aus dieser Fraktion
hören wir jeden Tag im Plenum also
halten sich lieber ein bisschen zurück
es ist an der Stelle gut und richtig
dass wir genau Hinweis geben der
Personen schützen die Hinweise auf
Beamte geben die auf die sie abzielen
mit ihren Rechten Strategien und es ist
deswegen auch wichtig weil sage das
Vertrauen in die Sicherheitsbehörden
stärken müssen das Vertrauen in
sicherheitsbündnis außerordentlich gut
aber es sind Durchschnittswerte und man
muss mal sagen wenn sie sich in
Stadtteile begeben wo Menschen leben
deren Einwanderungsgeschichte aus
anderen Ländern kommt oder deren Familie
ist das Vertrauen die
Sicherheitsbehörden deswegen nicht gut
und deswegen ist es eines von vielen
Maßnahmen Mosaiksteinen wo wir sagen wir
stärken hier das Vertrauen in die
Sicherheitsbehörden das ist im Interesse
der Sicherheitsbehörden lassen sich das
ausgerechnet von mir gesagt werden das
ist wichtig und deswegen müssen wir auch
diesen Teil schützen den hätten sie nie
mitgemacht in der Vergangenheit das ist
ein gutes Gesetz stimmen Sie dem zu dann
tun Sie etwas Gutes Glück auf schöne
Feiertage
sagt Sebastian Fiedler aus der
SPD-Fraktion wo er Sprecher der AG
Kriminalpolitik ist und er war vor
seiner Zeit im Deutschen Bundestag auch
eines der führenden Kräfte im Bund
Deutscher
Kriminalbeamter nächster Redner aus der
afd-fraktion Fabian Jacobi
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
wir behandeln den Entwurf der
Bundesregierung für ein Hinweisgeber
Schutzgesetz diese Stichwort findet sich
auch im Wahlprogramm der AFD dort heißt
es Zitat es bleiben oftmals nur noch
alternative Medien und Whistleblower zur
Aufdeckung und Offenlegung
regierungsamtlichen Unrechts aus diesem
Grund sind anonyme Hinweisgeber zur
Aufdeckung von Korruption
Machtmissbrauch und Straftaten und
verzichtbar sie hat Ende wir stehen also
dem Gedanken des hinweisgeberschutzes
nicht nur offen gegenüber sondern
fordern diesen ausdrücklich ein dennoch
werden wir dieses Gesetz gleich ablehnen
wie passt das zusammen wenn wir von
Hinweisgeber Schutz sprechen dann stehen
uns Personen wie Julian Assange oder
Edward Snowden vor Augen jene die aus
dem Inneren Leviathans Dinge ans Licht
holen von denen die mächtigen nicht
wollen dass sie gesehen werden um die
geht es bei diesem Gesetz hier aber eher
nicht angesprochen ist hier der normale
Mitarbeiter irgendein Unternehmens der
Dinge melden soll Vorgänge in seinem
Unternehmen zunächst einmal
rechtswidrige Vorgänge also
Gesetzesverstöße so weit so gut dann
aber eben auch Dinge die gerade nicht
rechtswidrig sind im Umkehrschluss also
legal sind die aber dem Ziel
irgendwelcher Vorschriften widersprechen
da wird es dann schon mulmig denn das
bedeutet dass man wenn etwa die
herrschenden Parteien hier neue Gesetze
machen sich nicht nur an das halten soll
was diese Gesetze explizit vorschreiben
sondern auch erspüren muss was
vielleicht noch alles dem Ziel eines
Gesetzes zu widerlaufen könnte
anderenfalls man gewertigen muss
gemeldet und gegebenenfalls
sanktionsfrei öffentlich angeprangert zu
werden da bekommt dieses Gesetz ganz
schnell eine ganz andere Tendenz nämlich
die einer allgemeinen gegenseitigen
Überwachung der Bürger ob der andere ob
der Arbeitgeber auch brav den Zielen der
Regierung folgt
besonders hervorgehoben wird der Bereich
des Steuerrechts da sollen nicht nur
strafbare Dinge also Steuerhinterziehung
gemeldet werden sondern jeglicher
Verstoß gegen steuerliche Vorschriften
oder wiederum gegen das Ziel
steuerlicher Vorschriften sieht man dann
noch dass das Gesetz zwar die
Verschwiegenheitspflichten der Ärzte und
der Rechtsanwälte berücksichtigt aber
die Verschwiegenheitspflicht der
Steuerberater und ihrer Mitarbeiter ganz
bewusst nicht einbezieht dann hört man
die sprichwörtliche Nachtigall hier
recht laut trapsen was ist aber nun mit
den aufdeckern von Korruption und
Machtmissbrauch aus dem Inneren des
Staates sind die wenigstens auch gemeint
von diesem Gesetz nicht wirklich denn
eine staatliche Stelle muss etwas nur
zur Verschlusssache erklären und schon
ist dieses Gesetz darauf nicht mehr
anwendbar gleichwohl er fährt auch der
innerstaatliche Bereich Aufmerksamkeit
offenbar in der Annahme dass die
Gelegenheit angesichts der aktuellen
dramatischen Berichte über sogenannte
Reichsbürger gerade günstig sei wurde im
Ausschuss noch ein Passus eingefügt
Staatsbedienstete sollen danach
insbesondere Meldung machen wenn ihre
Kollegen etwas äußern das gegen die
Pflicht zur Verfassungstreue verstößt
dagegen wären nun gar nichts zu sagen
solange es dabei um das herkömmliche
Verständnis von Verfassungstreue und
spiegelbildlich Verfassungsfeindlichkeit
ginge also um die Abschaffung von
Demokratie und Rechtsstaat das Menschen
die solches befürworten auf dem
Staatsdienst entfernt werden müssen das
unterliegt ja gar keinem Zweifel leider
aber leben wir in Zeiten in denen dieses
überkommene Verständnis von
Verfassungstreue zunehmend überlagert
wird von einem neuen Verständnis wonach
schon die Kritik an den Inhabern
staatlicher Ämter den Staat selbst die
legitimieren und damit
verfassungsfeindlich sein soll und damit
bekommt das Gesetz auch hier einen ganz
ominösen Beigeschmack das Sahnehäubchen
ist dann der beigestellte
Entschließungsantrag der
koalitionsfraktion in dem unter anderem
von finanziellen Vergünstigungen die
Rede ist also von
meldeprämien das weckt dann Erinnerungen
an einen anderen Staat und eine andere
Gesellschaftsordnung von der wir
annahmen sie seien 1990 auf den
Müllhaufen der Geschichte geflogen
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
nächster Redner für die Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen dr till Steffen und Till
Steffen ist einer der Parlamentarischen
Geschäftsführer der Fraktion Bündnis 90
die Grünen
Gerte frau Präsidentin meine Damen und
Herren nach dieser sehr verschwurbelten
Rede geht es glaube ich noch mal darum
ist es an der Zeit auch noch mal
deutlich zu machen worum es bei diesem
Gesetz wirklich geht es geht darum dass
es viele große Skandale gibt wirklich
mit großen Ausmaß die ohne
hinweisgeberinnen oder Hinweisgeber von
innen niemals ans Tageslicht gekommen
wären und wir sind ja schon einige
Beispiele von Sebastian Fiedler genannt
worden wenn wir das Thema cumex
südlicher ein ein Bereich wo ein großen
Umfang der größte steuerraubt unsere
Geschichten wie viele gesagt haben also
sowas ist nur ins Tageslicht gekommen
weil irgendjemand irgendwann von innen
gesagt hat hier passiert etwas wo ganz
gezielt Steuern hinterzogen werden
sollen sich sehr trickreiche Gestaltung
im Umgang mit der Steuer und
man sieht ja es ist gar keine Bagatelle
derjenige der das ganze erfunden hat
hanno Berger ist ja die Tage zu acht
Jahren Freiheitsstrafe verurteilt worden
das war so am Ende steht das Wirken von
Strafgerichten mit entscheiden mit
einschneidenden Sanktionen das ist das
was am Ende steht was am Anfang steht
ist der Hinweis von Menschen die
tatsächlich wissen was innen passiert
und ein entsprechenden Hinweis geben
können und überhaupt solche Ermittlungen
anstoßen können damit dann tatsächlich
entsprechend der Stadt handeln kann und
worum geht es also im Kern es geht darum
ob das was wir hier im Deutschen
Bundestag an Gesetzen beschließen
dass wir alle gilt oder ob das nicht
gilt für Leute die einfach nur mit
ausreichend großen Beträgen hantieren
oder die genug Ressourcen haben um ihr
kriminelles Handeln so zu verschleiern
mit ganz komplizierten Konstruktionen
während der einzelne einfache
Gewerbetreibende jederzeit das Finanzamt
im Nacken hat es geht also wirklich um
Gerechtigkeit es geht um die Frage ob
unser Rechtsstaat wirklich für alle gilt
und deswegen müssen wir ein großes
Interesse daran haben dass dieses Gesetz
in einer wirksamen Weise auch angewendet
wird
und tatsächlich was ist ja auch ganz
wichtig ist ist dass wir eingefügt haben
das verfassungsfeindliche Äußerungen von
Beamten und Beamten auch zum Gegenstand
von Hinweisen gemacht werden können sehr
ganz klar
Polizistinnen Polizisten sie leisten sie
leisten ein Eid auf das Grundgesetz auf
unsere Verfassung und wenn dann ein
Polizeibeamter sagt irgendwie kommt mir
das hier komisch vor hier reden in einer
Weise Kolleginnen und Kollegen die mit
der Verfassung nicht vereinbar sind zum
Beispiel rassistische Äußerungen die
natürlich die Sorge begründet erscheinen
lassen dass das sich auch im
polizeilichen Handeln niederschlägt dass
dieser Beamte dann bescheid sagt und
dafür sorgt dass dem entgegengewirkt
wird im frühen Stadium das absolut
richtig und das macht ja auch die Razzia
deutlich lieber vor wenigen Tagen hatten
wollen wir wirklich so lange warten bis
tatsächlich Leute Dienstwaffen entwenden
und sich gegen den Staat wenden oder
wollen wir früher intervenieren ich wäre
eindeutig für letzte ist
ganz wichtiger Bereich wo Whistleblowing
auch eine große Rolle spielt beim Thema
Tierschutz wir haben es ja erlebt in
Zeiten von Corona wo tatsächlich in
großen Fleischfabriken die
corona-auflagen missachtet wurden
Menschen zu Schaden kamen weil
tatsächlich entsprechende Vorkehrungen
nicht eingehalten worden da muss
natürlich zum Schutz der
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter die der
harte Arbeit leisten es möglich sein
hinzuweisen ohne dass das einschneidende
persönliche Konsequenzen hat und wir
haben einen weiteren Punkt hier an der
Stelle ergänzt wir haben es eben auch
ermöglicht dass Tierärzte die im
gewerblichen Bereich tätig sind dass die
auch darauf hinweisen können wir haben
vor wenigen Wochen darüber gesprochen
über die massenhafte Vergabe von
Antibiotika und da ist ja die Frage wie
soll das denn eigentlich bekannt werden
außer durch einen Tierarzt der natürlich
weiß was eine vernünftige Gabe von
Antibiotika ist und was tatsächlich
unvernünftig ist und dass da darauf
hingewiesen werden kann ist auch ein
wichtiger Schritt den wir durch dieses
Gesetz machen
und weil es ja auch einer der Punkte ist
die angesprochen wurden wir haben sehr
ausführlich mit Unternehmen gesprochen
von mit Compliance Stellen von großen
Unternehmen mit der Telekom mit
ThyssenKrupp mit Aurubis in Hamburg habe
ich gesprochen und sie haben ganz klar
gesagt natürlich bearbeiten wir auch
anonyme hin weil sie werden ja schön
blöd natürlich wollen wir Missständen
auf den Grund gehen und manchmal sind
die anonym Hinweise gerade die
interessantesten und alle haben gesagt
wenn man sich für die Bearbeitung dieser
Vorgänge sinnvollerweise eine
entsprechende Software zulegt dann bitte
schon der Standardprodukt die
Möglichkeit noch anonym Hinweise zu
verarbeiten also ihr Argument von
Mehrkosten kann ich an der Stelle nicht
nachvollziehen es gibt ein paar Punkte
es gibt ein paar Punkte die wir in
diesem Gesetz noch nicht ausreichend
abgebildet haben nach meiner Meinung
nach das ist die Frage ob auch Meldung
von Verstößen gegen das Allgemeine
Gleichbehandlungsgesetz ausreichend
abgebildet sind das wird im
Entschließungsantrag entsprechend noch
mal verfolgt und wir haben durchaus auch
Fälle wo es Meldungen geben kann aus dem
öffentlichen Interesse die im
öffentlichen Interesse legen die wir
auch nicht unbedingt ausreichend
abgebildet haben also etwa das Beispiel
von Brigitte Heinisch der Berliner
whistleblowerin die auf Missstände in
Pflegeheimen hinwies aber es ist ein
großer Schritt wir machen einen großen
Schritt nach vorne für den Schutz von
hinweisgeberinnen
letzten Wahlperiode die cdu/csu
erfolgreich diesen Schritt ausgesessen
hat und deswegen finde ich ihre Kritik
hier auch sehr sehr kleinteilig ich
finde bedauerlich dass der Bundesrat das
heute nicht aufgesetzt hat aber wir
werden natürlich dieses Gesetz auch
durchsetzen und das ist auch notwendig
zum Schutz von hinweisgeberinnen
Hinweisgebern und noch viel wichtiger
zum Schutz unseres Rechtsstaats und zur
gleichmäßigen Durchsetzung von Gesetzen
für alle vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
till steffen war das für die Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen der Bundestage
diskutiert nochmal über einen
Gesetzentwurf der Bundesregierung zum
besseren Schutz für Whistleblower oder
wie es hier heißt Hinweis gebende
Personen es geht auch um die Umsetzung
einer EU-Richtlinie die
koalitionsvertragsfraktionen haben
allerlei
Änderungsvorschläge eingebracht in
diesem Gesetzentwurf unter anderem in
Hinblick auf Hinweise auf Reichsbürger
beispielsweise in der Polizei gilt
steffen hat es eben erwähnt Klara Bünger
ist am Pool für die Linksfraktion
leider nur digital weil er ohne die
Gefahr der Auslieferung in die USA wo
eben eine hohe Strafe droht nicht nach
Deutschland reisen konnte für mich war
sein Handeln damals sehr beeindruckend
als er im Jahre 2013 die weltweite
massenüberwachung durch die NSA
aufdeckte und mit seinen Enthüllungen
das Ausmaß der überwachungs- und
spionagepraktiken von US-Geheimdiensten
der Öffentlichkeit zugänglich machte
denn nur durch diese Kenntnis und das
haben sie auch gesagt Herr Fiedler nur
durch diese Kenntnis und durch die
geliebten Informationen war es möglich
eine Diskussion eine breite Diskussion
in der Gesellschaft zu führen und ich
finde es ein Riesenskandal Herr Jakobi
dass sie den Namen etwas Snowden auch
nur in den Mund nehmen und für ihre
Hechte rechte Hetze verwenden das ist
wirklich ein riesen Skandal
schämen sie sich wenn er das wüsste er
würde nie ein Wort mit ihnen wechseln
bei vielen Menschen auch bei mir hat
seinen Mut sein Wissen über die massiven
Eingriffe in Grundrechte und diese mit
der Welt zu teilen und dabei seine
eigene Freiheit aufs Spiel zu setzen er
hat seine eigene
freiheits-gesetz sehr bewegt und ein
immensen Eindruck bei mir hinterlassen
whistleblowerin verdienen unsere
Anerkennung und unseren Schutz weil sie
nicht weil sie eben nicht zu ihrem
eigenen Vorteil Missstände aufdecken
sondern weil sie für unsere Demokratie
und unsere Rechtsstaatlichkeit tun und
davon und die ohne dieses insider wissen
während viele Straftaten und Skandale
niemals aufgedeckt worden die EU Wissen
Hinweisgeber Richtlinie wird nun endlich
ein Jahr nach Ablauf der Frist in
nationales Recht umgesetzt das ist gut
und das begrüßen wir auch
dennoch gibt es einige Punkte einige
Punkte wurden durch die Sachverständigen
Anhörung aufgenommen das ist gut wie zum
Beispiel die Pflicht zur Bearbeitung
anonymer Meldung wurde aufgenommen
erhebliche Lücken bestehen aber
weiterhin im staatlichen Bereich zwar
können jetzt auch Verstöße von Beamten
gegen die verfassungsfreulich gemeldet
werden das ist richtig und gerade nach
der reichsburger Razzia es wurde gesagt
auch dringend notwendig der Entwurf
versagt aber gerade bei whistleblowerin
denn ein deutscher Edward Snowden wäre
nach dem geplanten Gesetz nicht
geschützt denn Geheimdienste sind
komplett ausgenommen und Behörden können
Hinweise einfach unter den Teppich
kehren indem sie es Verschluss Sache
einstufen dabei wäre das doch ein
wichtiger Schritt Herr Fiedler wenn Sie
auch hier diese Person und Situation mit
einbeziehen würden
das Gesetz schützt außerdem nur bei
bestimmten Rechtsverstößen Hinweise auf
sonstige Fehlverhalten die
Machtmissbrauch oder Verstöße gegen das
allgemeine gleisbehandlungsgesetz sind
weiterhin nicht erfasst sie haben es
selbst angemerkt dabei steht es auch so
in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag und wir
würden uns wünschen dass sie da wirklich
zeitnah nachbessern der
Entschließungsantrag greift einige
Punkte zwar auf diese müssen jetzt aber
auch erstellten schnell umgesetzt werden
klarer Dünger Sprecherin für
Rechtspolitik in der Linksfraktion
kritisiert das Whistleblower in
Nachrichtendienste von einem besseren
Schutz ausgenommen seien in diesem neuen
Gesetz das nachher verabschiedet werden
wird von der Mehrheit der
Ampelkoalition kamen Weg jetzt für die
SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren der
dieselskandal im Automobilsektor die
bilanzmanipulation des wirecard-konzerns
diese wirtschaftskandale aus der
jüngsten Zeit hätten wahrscheinlich
verhindert werden können wenn Staat und
Öffentlichkeit nur rechtzeitig über das
notwendige Insiderwissen verfügt hätten
Insiderwissen das vor allem die
Beschäftigten dieser Unternehmen haben
aber warum haben sie ihr Wissen nicht
geteilt ganz einfach
Hinweisgeber in werden in ihren
Unternehmen drangsaliert gekündigt und
müssen um ihre wirtschaftliche Existenz
fürchten dem schieben wir nun einen
Riegel vor
mit dem hinweisgeberschutzgesetz
schlagen wir ein neues Kapitel im Schutz
von Whistleblower innen auf im
Gesetzgebungsverfahren haben wir hart
gerungen und wir haben viel Gutes
erreicht ich möchte drei Erfolge nennen
erstens wir haben ein eigenes
hinweisgeberschutzgesetz wir hätten die
EU-Richtlinie auch durch Änderungen
mehrere einzelgesetze umsetzen können
aber wir wollten Rechtssicherheit für
wisselblauer in wenn sie noch zögern ein
Missstand öffentlich zu machen sollen
sie in nur ein Gesetz schauen müssen
dann wissen Sie was für sie gilt
zweitens wir schützen Menschen die
Verstöße auch gegen nationales Recht
Anzeigen laut Richtlinie hätten wir den
Schutz der wisselblauer in nur einführen
müssen wenn die Person Verstöße gegen EU
Recht melden also zum Beispiel Verstöße
gegen das Datenschutzrecht dieser Schutz
hätte viele Lücken gelassen so jedoch
wird Hinweis gebenden Personen mehr
richtig Sicherheit gegeben mein Kollege
Sebastian Fiedler hat das schon
ausgeführt und drittens nicht zuletzt
haben wir in den Behandlung einen neuen
Schutzbereich für Beamtinnen geschaffen
das wurde heute auch schon häufiger
gesagt Beamtin sind nun vor
dienstrechtlichen Konsequenzen geschützt
wenn Sie Hinweise auf Äußerungen von
Kolleginnen melden die an deren Pflicht
zur Verfassungstreue zweifeln lassen das
können insbesondere auch Nachrichten
oder Bilder in chatgruppen sein in denen
Beamtinnen umstutzfantasien und
staatsfeindlichkeit äußern leider sind
solche chatgruppen kein Einzelfall umso
wichtiger ist es dass wir davon erfahren
mit heute hat der alte korbsgeist also
ausgedient wenn es um die Treue zur
Verfassung geht stattdessen stehen die
Demokratien wieder einmal geschlossen
zusammen mit der heutigen Verabschiedung
des hinweisgeberschutzgesetzes ist
unsere Arbeit als Gesetzgeber aber noch
nicht fertig unsere Entschließungsantrag
macht sehr deutlich an welchen Bereichen
wir in künftigen Gesetzen weiter
arbeiten wollen um den Schutz von Wissen
blauer in weiter zu stärken auch hier
möchte ich drei Punkte nennen ersten
Staatsgeheimnisse wir wollen den
hinweisgeberschutz in den Bereichen der
nationalen Sicherheit der
Nachrichtendienste der werbeauftragten
und im Bereich der Verschluss Sachen
modernisieren gerade hier ist die
Abwägung zwischen dem
aufdeckungsinteresse und dem Schutz der
nationalen Sicherheit besonders heikel
das stimmt schon trotzdem müssen wir
diese Abwägung vornehmen und
hinweisgeberinnen unter festen
schutzstellen zweitens im Bereich der
verschlussachen wollen wir prüfen wie
wir zügig eine unabhängige
Kontrollinstanz aufbauen die für die
Fragen Hinsicht der hinsichtlich der
materiellen Einstufung von
Verschlusssachen zuständig ist dies wird
auch im Hinblick auf das neue
bundesdaten
bundesstransparenzgesetz wichtig sein
drittens nicht zuletzt werden wir
beobachten ob hinreichend gewährleistet
ist das hinweisgebende Personen bei der
Meldung von Verstößen gegen das
Allgemeine Gleichbehandlungsgesetz
geschützt sind genauso wenn sie
sonstiges erhebliches Fehlverhalten
melden dessen Aufdeckung im besonderen
öffentlichen Interesse liegt
ich will abschließend ganz deutlich
werden wer die Hinweisgeber Ihnen als
den sozial in verunglimpft hat noch
nichts verstanden
ein Dienst an unserer Gesellschaft ihnen
rufe ich zu Hartmut der Staat wird euren
Mut von heute an schützen vielen Dank
Carmen Wecker aus der SPD-Fraktion war
die vorletzte Rednerin in dieser Debatte
die letzte jetzt Susanne hürl aus der
Unionsfraktion die Unionsfraktion hat
einen Entschließungsantrag eingebracht
nicht ganz unwahrscheinlich dass Susanne
hier den einen und anderen Satz dazu
noch sagen wird jetzt
sehr geehrte Frau Präsiden
tin und Kollegen bei meiner Rede zur
ersten Lesung des
hinweisgeberschutzgesetzes hatte ich sie
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der
Ampel darum gebeten die Zeit bis zur
zweiten und dritten Lesung zu nutzen um
die Anregungen aus der Praxis also der
Unternehmen die die Regelungen umsetzen
sollen und der Hinweisgeber die durch
die Regelungen geschützt werden sollen
mit in das Gesetz einfließen zu lassen
so wie sie sich das in ihrem
Koalitionsvertrag auch vorgegeben haben
lassen sie uns überprüfen was sich im
Vergleich zum ersten Gesetzentwurf getan
hat und ob sich Verbesserungen für die
Praxis ergeben wir versetzen uns dafür
in die Lage eines potentiellen
Hinweisgebers also eines Arbeitnehmers
in einer Behörde oder einen Unternehmen
der einen Verstoß entdeckt und überlegt
sich diesen überlegt diesen zu melden
für den Hinweisgeber stellt sich heute
noch immer die Frage ob der Verstoß in
der melden will überhaupt in den
Anwendungsbereich des Gesetzes fällt und
er dadurch geschützt ist sie lassen den
Hinweisgeber weiterhin mit der Klärung
dieser Frage und den unbestimmten
Rechtsbegriffen alleine das ist kein
hinweisgeberschutz
hat der Hinweisgeber entschieden dass er
den Verstoß meldet hat er zu überlegen
wo er der Meldung erstattet dies kann er
entweder intern bei seinem Arbeitgeber
tun oder eben sich an eine externe
Meldestelle wenden entgegen der
sinnvollen Empfehlung der EU-Richtlinie
die interne der externen Meldung
vorzuziehen sah der bisherige
Gesetzentwurf keine Rangfolge der
Meldungen vor diesen Punkt haben viele
Sachverständige bereits in der
Verbändeanhörung und auch in der
Sachverständigen Anhörung bemängelt
im Änderungsantrag Unternehmen Sie nun
den zaghaften Versuch der internen
Meldung den Vorzug zu geben leider
bleibt es bei einem Versuch es gibt
lediglich eine halbherzige Aufforderung
an die Unternehmen Anreize für die
interne Meldung zu schaffen
der die
exzelle den Hinweisgeber in
geeig auf die Möglichkeit einer internen
Meldung hinweisen soll wirft mehr Fragen
auf als sie beantwortet ist mit dem
Hinweis dass externe Verfahren beendet
was passiert wenn der Hinweisgeber auf
diesen Hinweis hin den Verstoß
zusätzlich intern meldet wird dann
doppelt bearbeitet und durch den Umweg
über die externe Meldestelle geht
weiterhin viel Zeit verloren diese Zeit
hätte das Unternehmen nutzen können um
den Missstand abzustellen denn genau
darauf kommt es doch an die Missstände
zu erkennen und schnell abzustellen ich
hoffe nicht
dass das der Unternehmensschutz ist von
dem Sie Herr Minister Buschmann in ihren
Ausführungen zur ersten Lesung
gesprochen haben
unser Hinweisgeber will nun den Verstoß
anonym melden denn er ist selbst
Beteiligter
bisher war im Gesetzentwurf nicht
verpflichten vorgesehen dass eine
Meldung auch anonym abgegeben werden
kann das hätte den Hinweisgeber in
unserem Fall davon abgehalten zu melden
die Möglichkeit der anonymenmeldung
haben sie entgegen anfänglicher
vehementer Ablehnung in der ersten
Debatte nun in das Gesetz mit
aufgenommen und machen die Möglichkeit
zur Abgabe einer anonymenmeldung
verpflichtend außerdem können die
Meldestellen und selbst entscheiden
welchen Hinweisen sie zuerst noch gehen
die Priorisierung der Bearbeitung der
nicht anonymenmeldungen vor den anonymen
Meldungen wurde aufgehoben das ist
einmal ein großer Schritt hin zu mehr
Praxisnähe es bleibt fest zu halten das
war einige gute
praxisrelevante Änderungen aufgenommen
wurden jedoch bleibt der Gesetzentwurf
weit hinter den Erwartungen für ein
gutes und vor allem
praxistaugliches Gesetz zurück
Fortschritt meine liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Ampel zieht anders aus
herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
ich schließe die Aussprache wir kommen
zur Abstimmung über den von der
Bundesregierung eingebrachten
Gesetzentwurf für einen besseren Schutz
Hinweis gebender Personen sowie zur
Umsetzung der Richtlinie zum Schutz von
Personen die Verstöße gegen das
Unionsrechts melden der Rechtsausschuss
empfiehlt unter Buchstabe a seiner
Beschlussempfehlung auf Drucksache
4.909 den Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung auf Drucksachen
3442 und
3.709 in der ausschussfassung anzunehmen
hierzu liegt ein Änderungsantrag der
Fraktion der AFD auf Drucksache
4969 vor wir stimmen zuerst über den
Änderungsantrag ab wer stimmt für diesen
Antrag das ist die afd-fraktion wer
stimmt dagegen
das sind die übrigen Fraktionen des
Hauses damit ist der Änderungs also
Enthaltung Entschuldigung damit ist der
Änderungsantrag abgelehnt
ich bitte diejenigen die dem
Gesetzentwurf in der ausschussfassung
zustimmen wollen um das Handzeichen
das sind die
Koalitionsfraktionen wer stimmt dagegen
cdu/csu-fraktion und die afd-fraktion
Enthaltungen die Fraktion DIE LINKE der
Gesetzentwurf ist damit in zweiter
Beratung angenommen dritte Beratung und
Schlussabstimmung ich bitte diejenigen
die dem Gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen
sich zu erheben
das sind die Koalitionsfraktionen wer
stimmt dagegen
die cdu/csu-fraktion afd-fraktion
Enthaltungen die Fraktion DIE LINKE
damit ist der Gesetzentwurf in dritter
Beratung angenommen
weiterhin empfiehlt der Ausschuss unter
Buchstabe c seine Beschlussempfehlung
auf Drucksache
40009 eine Entschließung anzunehmen wer
stimmt für diese Beschlussempfehlung
das sind die Fraktionen die Linke SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und die FDP wer
stimmt dagegen
cdu/csu-fraktion die afd-fraktion
Enthaltungen sehe ich nicht die
Beschlussempfehlung ist damit angenommen
wir kommen nun zur Abstimmung über den
Entschließungsantrag der Fraktion der
cdu/csu auf Drucksache 4.914 wer stimmt
für diesen Entschließungsantrag das ist
die cdu/csu-fraktion wer stimmt dagegen
das sind die Fraktion DIE LINKE
spd-bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP
Enthaltungen die afd-fraktion denn
schließungsantrag ist damit abgelehnt
und damit ist auch dieser
Tagesordnungspunkt am sogenannten
angekommen